hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
Slenderman shadows maps in this one will
play carnival but all of the maps have
been remade in the Unity engine I
believe and they've been remastered all
the things you can see all the different
options are here in their respective
colors and the new one which is carnival
is the one that I will be playing today
I don't know if I'm gonna be revisiting
these but these two are new the
Christmas special in the carnival
obviously it was late to the game with
the Christmas special but at whatever
Christmas is only 300 and some odd days
away so I'll get to it eventually but
for now let's get to it I'm done been a
while since I played a the Slenderman
shadow enough they were really prevalent
during like September oh hello collect
all eight pieces of evidence evidence
evidence of what wait where is it oh is
that a roller coaster it's hard to see
its really dark it's a lot darker than
the other map said I remember but then
again it is a whole new engine it's
actually the same engine that the
original Slender the pages was made in
hello so there are going to be some
similarities but a lot of new effort and
work was put into this one I'm guessing
I don't know I wasn't there for the
development but
like the atmosphere sounds are really
really nice creepy in a lot of ways all
right it said I was looking for evidence
but I don't know what evidence means I
don't know what evidence looks like what
kind of ed of it evidence and for what
crime obviously we're in a abandoned old
carnival for so I'm pretty sure that my
first time I'm gonna die like most of
the times I play slender and have no
idea what the map is like it's his trash
can evidence nope yeah like most times
when I play a slender map for the first
time I die a lot
all right so what's that something kind
of popped up on my radar candy candy all
right man there are a lot of buildings
this isn't like any carnival I've ever
been do actually now that I think about
I don't I don't think I've ever been to
a carnival there's something glowing on
the distance over there also sounds like
something's like a tarp flapping in the
wind
all right anyway what hello somebody
there what's a car and a bubble soda
machine I know Cola why is there a car
in the middle of this place for what
purpose
oh it's a truck nevermind sorry why was
that there's another glow over there I
still haven't I haven't seen a single
thing I don't know if I'm looking for
pages or items or what have you
huh why did my father I got out why did
that happen is it some bad way the hell
is that
some on the ground over there and let me
see something here yeah oh god damn it
[ __ ] hell I saw that
alright I'm an idiot I saw the mirror
attic look never mind shut up shut up
don't judge me my god
I'm not a big baby the mirror looked
like Slenderman shut up alright got a
find ever Det ah not really is slender
where the hell was he I didn't even see
him where was he
I don't even see him bring it on don't
don't [ __ ] with my flashlight I really
don't need that is this evidence it's an
ashtray evidence
what is the evidence what kind of
evidence I don't even know how big this
place is the moon evidence I don't know
rollerCoaster evidence evidence of what
I seem to have reached the limit of the
map here and there's a lot of flicker
going on okay so I've reached I've gone
from one end to the other and it doesn't
help me at all because I have no idea
where I am still oh hi hey how's it
going friend you showed up early I
haven't even found one you're late to
the party go home unless this is your
home are you some clown that got fired
and then he decided to get revenge on
everyone by killing all the little
kitties that mocked you it all makes
sense
hmm mark slender retired clown
I still haven't found anything at all I
mean and I am getting a feel for the map
but I would have thought that by now I
would have found something then again
not knowing what I'm looking for kind of
inhibits my progress I'm reaching the
boundaries of the map definitely there's
another wall over there and I've gone in
a lot of these buildings so I don't know
if they're like really really
well-hidden or what yeah I haven't found
anything
there ain't nothing well wait what's
this
how's this evidence oh there are
paintings pictures pieces of paper I
didn't see that on anything else
oh the old familiar thumping ah I
haven't really played a lot of slender
games in a while you know waiting for
all the big name ones to be released you
know I guess this qualifies as a big
name one because it's now more
professional release for the guy who
made it guys name is mark Steen the
website is obviously linked in the
description below you can find it and
play it for yourself wait nice
I keep seeing like these little white
glows and glowing things in the
background and I keep thinking that
their pages because before that's what
the identifying marker the pages were
but now I have almost nothing to go on
and I'm back to the beginning I remember
this I was here before ah
oh you're moving you're kind of doing a
shuffle there ha how did he get me I
only had one I didn't even get a warning
it was he like but b'doop and then
you're dead
what the hell okay this is considerably
harder because number one the pages have
no lighting on them they have no
illumination or anything they're just
kind of blend in with the environment I
mean that one that I found would have
been very easy to overlook but now that
I know what I'm looking for as I go
through the map again I have a better
idea of the layout and I'll do gooder
there's something out of them okay so
now I kind of know what I'm looking for
they must be all located in these kind
of places is that something is that
right in front of me something
no that's cotton candy that's not a
Paige cotton candy why is that more
illuminated than anything why is that
more illuminated than anything else come
on out come on out you Paige's evidence
of what evidence that Slenderman is a
really bad artist is that what we're
collecting evidence for uh I'm guessing
that there there is kind of there's got
to be some sort of time limit because
even though I only found one he kind of
found me pretty quick and he started
creeping up like after a very short
amount of time so there's gotta be
something along those lines of a time
limit was this that's evidence that how
am I supposed to find anything that was
impossible to see oh god I'm dead I'm
doomed I'm so dead I'm so dead there's
no way I'm gonna get anything here
there's no way I'm gonna get anything
this is this ball this ball those are
like tiny itty bitty baby shoes I'm
overloading my mic by yelling I'm upset
what are you you're just a giant
concrete what should I call it what are
you
oh I found two whatever the hell that
was it was a dirty rag what kind of lame
investigator am i huh I've got a used
dish rag some baby booties slenderman in
the lobby
what's the wrench I don't know with the
some well I know what this is might be
important but I didn't see anything
clickable I'm the MacGyver of Slenderman
clues okay there's the I guess that's
sort of a landmark there's one thing I'm
just trying to go in each of the
buildings to find something so they're
not all pages they're not all paintings
like they're just random items scattered
throughout not bet I bet the guy who
made this wanted to make it a lot harder
I know because I've talked to him before
and he said I want to make these a lot
are more challenging and by doing that
he said I'm gonna be huge I heard dick
and hide of it all the most
inconspicuous items possible he's not
dick he's a nice guy but he's our deck
dummy right now that's it that's all
there is to it
oh the old familiar thumpety thump
messin with my flashlight again aren't
we all right done we'll see who has the
last laugh bozo the Slenderman whoa whoa
oh what's that what is that what is that
who's there oh oh wait what
hey look it's promotion I don't know who
this guy is but hey congratulations
you're in the game what if I'm in the
game probably not really not yeah
is anybody here oh yeah yeah
nothing nothing again whole lot of
nothing
let me go check the outskirts of the
place because like I don't know I don't
know maybe it's quite possible that
something was hidden in the woods area
it's hard to see there's not something
reflecting off this flashlight it's
almost impossible to see which is
actually correct and how light works and
not reflecting can't see anything okay
anyway hi whoa whoa
I sorry I said the wall back up there
dick where the hell did you come from
what the whoo whoo I see something how
do I get you I'm gonna getcha I'm gonna
getcha that looks like a picture of
Slendy holding hands with a little kid
yeah it is
oh he's not that bad actually is pretty
bad hey fun is that you know and when
you're caught it never says he kills you
it just says that you're caught
ah-ah-ah-ah
oh no that's just another promotional
thing
stupid carnival 101 guy Joe
I know your text oh I see you oh you
were right up oh you're moving look his
arms moving look he's got him animations
he's not just a static figure ah static
figure nice arm so you've been doing
your tricep curls
I know tricep curls are impossible I go
on the gaga
man when he wants to get you he gotcha
like seriously I don't even have a
chance it's kind of like slender prison
mechanics of them there's got to be a
time limit because I'm not I am not up
to par on this I'm definitely not up to
par all right I'm gonna run from the
get-go which is a strategy held over
from the ancient times of Babylonia no
no all right so where did I find the
other ones I found one right away on the
picnic table I wonder if they're in the
same spot if it's not that'll give me a
good idea that they're entirely
randomized and we'll definitely seal the
idea that I am boned wait was this
they're randomized I'm [ __ ] beyond
imagination yay
okay you're ready to run the pain train
of death I don't know this place is
actually fairly large a fairly large I
found the rag behind this place here I'm
guessing that I need to run a lot see if
there's anything in here I I have a
feeling this has got to be important
like this weird concrete building here
and no purpose to it but oh well see ah
hello rag oh no that was a dress oh that
wasn't a used dish rag that was a dress
it's like a little kids dress Slenderman
you be creepy hey you be creepy stop
being creepy I think the game maker put
all those little glowy things in the
distance to make you think that it's
Slendy out there
yeah okay here's that thing is that guy
again its poster ah what the hell
sounded like a tire squealing who is
driving around here and why can't I get
out of here
okay I'm wondering it this mirror I
don't like that mirror I don't like the
mirrors on that thing come on
Slendy back off I will shove my fist up
your ass then manipulate you like a
puppet do you like that Slendy would you
like that probably would you sicko
aha look like he had dick four hands
balls for his fingers you heard my side
eh I'm insulting you because I know
you're not really gonna show me any
mercy when you kill me anyway
so or whatever you do when you capture
me right
in other news I really do like this
level it's very confusing all of the
stuff looks the same which is scarda to
target target dark give me my money back
give it back give it back give it back
wizard moon where's it Engle there was
no moon he took away the moon wait ah
thank you for pointing me in the right
direction I would have totally missed
that four of eight four of eight oh no
the music has shifted okay that's all
the items that I remember collecting
it's just that that's literally I
remember seeing those besides the new
one which look like Slenderman had penis
fingers Oh No
hi he's gonna get me he is going to
exploit me in very horrifying ways I
have a feeling I'm about to be caught
really really soon
so far so good one thing that I would I
don't like is some of these walls here
are have no thickness to them like these
walls here there and there's some
clipping going on there ah top level
designing stop criticizing ah hey buddy
hello again hi good to see you it's hard
I don't know the possible spawn
locations just yet I got some learning
to do before I can beat this I would
need to like really really try at this
because I mean there are said spawn
locations but they randomly change what
items are there or something like that I
don't know it's slightly randomized
slightly not I have no idea so if you
were hoping that I was gonna beat it
well you probably weren't cuz you know
me you know me I can't beat anything
with the dam but anyway now it's really
good I really like the remake I might I
may actually visit some of the other
maps I made because I kind of want to
see what was done differently I mean
it's a new engine but it's also he said
he changed a lot of the mechanics so
hope you all enjoyed it click the link
in the description below to be taken to
the developers website and you can try
out for themselves so you there's tons
of maps there's like let's see how many
are there there's tons
there's tons of maps tons of them and
I'll do this in a different video the
Christmas special morning or will I yeah
I'll do it in a different one okay so
that's it for there so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
ah